you've probably heard about the wolf of
wall street the stock market fraudster
that made millions pumping and dumping
penny stocks during his time in the
business the wolf of wall street managed
to steal a whopping 200 million dollars
while that's a terrible figure when you
take a look at alan stanford's fraud the
wolf of wall street looks like a rookie
allen ran a ponzi scheme for nearly 20
years and defaulted a total of 7.2
billion dollars which is the second
largest in history
so here's how allen stole 7.2 billion
dollars and then nearly got away with it
taking a look back alan stanford was
born on march 24 1950 in mexia texas
his father james stanford was actually a
former mayor of mexia and his mother was
a nurse it seems like allen performed
pretty well academically he graduated
from eastern hills high school and
attended baylor university where he
earned a finance degree in 1974
while at baylor allen lived with a man
named james davis who would eventually
become allen's right-hand man in the
ponzi scheme
anyway after graduation allen decided to
take a shot at legitimate
entrepreneurship his father had a pretty
good reputation in the town and this was
during the crazy inflation crisis of the
1970s so banks were desperate to loan
out as much money as possible to combat
high inflation
this made it pretty easy for alan to
borrow a large amount of money and open
a string of gyms according to allen's
workout buddies allen wasn't extremely
tall and muscular man coming in at 6
feet 5 inches and 330 pounds so you
would think that running a gym would be
right up his alley but this wasn't the
case
allen ran these gyms for several years
but in 1982 he was forced to close them
down after racking up 13 million dollars
in personal debt despite this massive
loss allen would start a real estate
business with his father
this was actually great timing as the
texas real estate market was getting
crushed
throughout the 1970s oil prices had
skyrocketed due to the inflation crisis
but as inflation slowed down in the
1980s oil got crushed given that the
texan economy was quite dependent on oil
the texan economy also got crushed which
of course includes real estate allen and
his father made a killing buying up real
estate at the bottom and flipping it as
the market recovered this was honestly a
great business and i think allen should
have just talked to real estate the
company was growing rapidly and was able
to support 500 employees but things
would start getting shady as ellen
started making serious money in the
1980s allen moved to the caribbean
islands presumably to reduce his tax
load allen first settled on the british
islands of monserrat in 1985
but the british started cracking down on
monster route residents around the same
time so alan jumped over to the island
of antigua
at this point allen might have been
using some tax loopholes and though
that's morally wrong it's not illegal
but it didn't take long for alan to jump
over the legal boundary as well
in 1991 allen founded a financial
institution called stanford
international bank in antigua and james
davis was appointed cfo
allen realized that many wealthy latin
americans were worried about their
corrupt governments collapsing and
taking other currencies with them so
they were looking for international
diversification opportunities and alan
leveraged this in order to really sell
the stability of his bank allen moved
the headquarters to houston texas and
associated himself with the american
dollar allen started selling
certificates of deposits or cds which
are basically just high-yield savings
accounts with terms the longer you agree
to keep your money in the account the
higher the annual interest rate allen
cds generally boasted returns that were
above average but this alone isn't
really a red flag here's the thing the
market average is dominated by the big
banks like chase wells fargo and
citigroup and these guys offer trash
interest rates chase bank for example
offers a whopping 0.05
return if you sign up for a 10-year cd
this isn't to say that chase isn't
generating great returns themselves
though in the second quarter of 2021
chase generated an roi of 8.16 percent
which is the highest it's been in the
last 15 years now of course interest
rates were much better in the 1990s but
the big banks and the market average are
always relatively low because they don't
need to offer competitive rates to
attract clients so it's quite common for
up-and-coming banks to offer attractive
rates to appeal to new customers
it seemed like stanford financial group
was just another going bank trying to
get ahead and i bet alan could have made
that the reality but he didn't instead
alan decided to make his cd business a
ponzi scheme the details of how exactly
allen pulled out the scam are not public
for obvious reasons the sec doesn't want
future criminals trying to replicate
alan's fraud but given that it was a
ponzi scheme i think it's safe to assume
that alan was using new deposits to pay
out the interest rates of old deposits
and given how fast his bank was growing
paying out all depositors with new
deposits wasn't that difficult just
three years after founding the company
the bank's assets had ballooned to 350
million dollars
allen maintained sizable operations in
antigua which quickly made him the
largest employer on the island by the
end of the 1990s stanford's total
deposits grew to 3 billion
meaning that allen was officially
defrauding in the billions but this was
just the beginning
moving on to the 2000s allen started
splurging with his depositor's money
allen spent 100 million dollars buying a
helicopter and a private jet and he
spent 12 million dollars to extend his
yacht by six feet
in 2006 allen became knighted by the
antiquing government which meant that he
could use the title sir similar to sir
richard branson
in the meantime allen was branching out
the business from latin american
customers to international customers and
growing the deposits exponentially
it might have been a better idea to keep
the bank relatively small so that it
would stay under the radar but once
again that's not what alan did
by 2008 the stanford group had investors
from 140 countries with a total of 50
billion under management this made allen
a multi-billionaire worth 2.2 billion
dollars
but things weren't so good under the
hood the sec and the fbi were starting
to get suspicious that the stanford
financial group was able to pay out
above average returns for 17 years
straight the sec had already been
suspicious about the group since 1997. a
lawsuit against the icc actually
suggested that the sec had looked into
the stanford group four times between
1997 and 2008 and that they were acutely
aware of their fraud allen was running
they weren't aware of the size or depth
of the scheme but it looks like they did
know that something was off however they
didn't take any further action
when this case against the sec went to
court the sec spokesman john nestor took
the fifth and declined to comment so
maybe allen bribes some scc officials to
let him slide by or maybe the sec had
just been ignorant either way though
allen's luck was about to run out thanks
to the 2008 financial recession with
major institutions like lehman brothers
collapsing the sec and fbi decided that
it was time to crack down on all
financial institutions which of course
included the stanford financial group
once the sec and fbi started
investigating it it didn't take them
long to figure out that something was
seriously wrong with the institution
they simply started off by filing civil
charges against ellen though so they
clearly did not know the extent of the
fraud but soon enough they created a
warrant for his arrest alan heard about
this news and contacted a private jet
owner and tried to fly out of the
country
at this point allen's passport hadn't
been seized and allen wasn't convicted
of anything so the private jet owner
didn't have a problem with flying allen
out of the country however fate would
screw over allen the private jet company
only accepted wire transfers so allen
was unable to pay with his credit card
unable to flee the country the fbi would
arrest allen on june 18 2009 but this
was okay with alan as he had further
measures in place to protect his freedom
allen refused to admit his guilt and
maintain that he was completely innocent
at first this might sound a bit
confusing if he had defaulted investors
of seven billion dollars there was no
way he was going to get away with it at
this point so it would make way more
sense to just plead guilty right well
let's just say alan had some friends at
the sec
inspector general h david kotz was
assigned to investigate the case and i
don't know how he did it but somehow he
came out with a report in march of 2010
that the sec had dropped the ball on
stanford
the sec's chief investigator also felt
that this was super suspicious so he
brought in inspector general david c
williams to conduct an independent
review
over the next few years the sec and fbi
would uncover a total of 7.2 billion
worth of frauds the key to uncovering
all of this was allen's college buddy
and cfo james davis james basically
spilled the beans in exchange for a
reduced sentence james admitted that his
entire job was to just make up numbers
and that that's what he had been doing
since 1988. in the meantime allen wasn't
having a very pleasant time in jail as
one of his geomates would severely beat
him up
i'm not going to put up any pictures but
let's just say it wasn't pretty
anyway allen was sentenced to 110 years
in prison on june 14 2012 and he's been
rotting in prison ever since
he did file for an appeal but that was
eventually thrown out as for his partner
james davis he was only sentenced to
five years since he spilled the beans so
i think he should be out by now
unfortunately the same could not be said
about the investors that stand for
defrauded as most of them were never
able to get out of the hole that allen
put them in
many of stanford group's cd investors
lost every single penny they put in and
this has caused many to suggest that
ellen's fraud was even worse than bernie
madoff scam at least with bernie most
investors got a substantial portion of
their money back when everything was
said and done
but that's not the case with allen and
that's how alan stanford stole 7.2
billion dollars
what do you guys think about allen's
gmail to beating him up comment that
down below
also drop a like if you wish alan was
caught much earlier and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm ari and i'll see you guys on
the next one